[Music]  good evening  [Music]  oh wait you're just a civilian now  mr james ford general ryan is requesting  your  inimitable counsel no  he's offered to reinstate you  from the top four hours ago the crew of  the vander made first contact  stay there  in the event of first contact humanity  must strike first  to ensure the continued survival  of our species operation  cosmic sin is now a go  not there because of space gate  they can bring their army here  what's the status of the cuba if we want  to launch the cue bomb  we need to get into orbit suit's up  that's something huh we didn't know  whether to burn it we put it in a museum  i'm sure they said the same thing about  me  if we leave that door open we're gonna  charge in  we can make this the kill box  we're not gonna wait for them to bring  the fight to us  we're gonna take it to them what we do  here  is easy  the hard part is living with it  [Music]  you